does this whole
system of viruses that interact with
each other and so damn good at getting
inside our bodies
does that fascinate you or terrify you
i'm very much a scientist and so
uh it fascinates me much more than it
terrifies me
uh but knowing enough i know just how
well
you know we get the wrong virus um
in our population whether it's through
some random mutation or whether it's
this same cova-19 virus and it
you know these things are tricky they're
able to mutate quickly they're able to
uh find new hosts and rearrange in the
case of influenza
so what terrifies me is just how easily
this particular pandemic could have been
so much worse this could have been a
virus that is
uh much worse than it is you know same
thing with h1n1 back in 2009
that terrifies me if a virus like that
was much more detrimental
uh you know that would be it could be
much more devastating although it's hard
to say you know the the human
species were well
i i hesitate to say that we're good at
responding to things because there are
some aspects that were
this particular virus stars cove too and
covet 19 has
found a sweet spot where where it's not
quite serious enough on an individual
level that humans just don't
we haven't seen much of a useful
response by many humans
like a lot of people even think it's a
hoax and so it's led us down this path
of
uh it's not quite serious enough to get
everyone to respond immediately
and with the most urgency but it's
enough
it's bad enough that you know it's
caused our economies to shut down and
collapse and so
um i think i know enough about virus
biology to be
terrified for humans that you know it
can it just takes one virus
just takes the wrong one to just
obliterate us or
not obliterate us but but really do much
more damage than we've seen
you